and they face a resurgent luis castillo
his season numbers from western and
southern they don't do him justice no
they don't do him justice at all
recently he's been really good hopefully
he can continue the trend
seen that fastball notch up 98 miles an
hour devastating change up swing of the
miss
castillo showing off his full array
the high heat
and the soft swinging miss
[Applause]
grounds into the shift in between farmer
gloves spinning throw
took a tumble
and he makes the play
farm doesn't look to be too happy about
that play
you can see right there
when you go into that shift situation
nice
spinning throw to first base actually
work on that but you go into that shift
you have to take a little different
angle because you can see india right
there
farm probably taking a little more
shallow of an angle that he wanted to
because if not he's running right into
jonathan india right there
blasted indian climb the ladder makes
the pick
two down
castillo's pitch swing to the miss he
struck him out
and down on strikes bradley jr castillo
works around the one out single
back-to-back walks from woodrow no
chance for shogo akiyama
double play ball thomas quick flip wall
it's lost in first by peterson nikon
breaks for home akiyama
[Applause]
strides in the second standing and rbi
double two nothing cincinnati
and in the hole at thomas big arm oh
that is mesmerizing to watch this guy
play
that is something else
the big throwing arm when they talk to
adamus about that does he ever have a
sore arm he says well not really
but once he got to that baseball
and suarez running you knew he had a
shot he gets up and his throwing arm
flat footed
right on the money got him by a couple
of steps that's a really good throw good
play
a lot of guys get to that baseball but
don't have the arm to get the out yeah
that was a seed
william thomas is due up he and luis
castillo have been
a little playful with one another
tonight
and a lot of communication on the field
and
i think this was after the first at bat
[Music]
where willie adams had a single
and then after the second
at that you see his smile
the slider and he's like yeah yeah yeah
you got me on that one
1-2
slider down
second time tonight that castillo has
fanned to dominate
two balls two strikes
[Applause]
and a base hit the center field
good start to the seventh brewers
finally saw a hanging slider didn't see
any with castillo out there
and another base hit against the lefty
taylor turns second here comes the throw
runners at the corners nobody out of the
seventh get to that bullpen
little tapper up the line stevenson will
play it out number one but taylor is in
that worked
first run of the night for the brewers
tying run now standing at second two to
one reds out in front brewers are the
runner at second and one away
william thomas the batter and a base
head into right field
here comes colton wong rounding third
through to the plate is safe at home
and this game is tied as once again
willie and davis delivers
narvaez into center field coming out off
the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whether he caught it or not
would have scored he was tagging up the
whole way
once again the bruise with some late
offense jumping off the mat
and taking the lead well he caught it
hey that's a catch on live like i
thought he had probably that's a catch
i'm not sure how the empire's missed
that that's really not even close
this should take all about 10 seconds
and we uh swept past that already yeah
right
uh what you think is obvious might not
be
down that on the second inning there you
go got it
and one scores yep so everything
everything is as we thought catch
sac fly council making sure he turned
out yeah he tagged that correctly you
can see it clearly
[Applause]
and the umpires are saying that's it
they're waving the players off the field
made it back they want the target
it is a hard downpour
with an 0-1 count
9 55 p.m we have hit a rain delay
there is a member of the crew
under the tarp
on yeah right there
gamer
uh oh
tart mobster
oh
that's tough
it looks like he's having fun down there
absolutely
i've been there i pulled many a tarp in
the miners trailing by a run they need
to score
they've only had two hits tonight tucker
barnhart at the plate
brewer pitching his retired 10
reds in a row
cousins looking to finish a delayed one
two three inning and he does just that a
strike out of barnhart
and that is good work what rain delay
says jake cousins let's move to the
eighth a one run lead for the crew
well welcome back michael lorenzen
season's long work of getting back to
this point
and
he wanted to be thrown into the fire
here he is
that's a good looking pitch and there's
a late ring up straight through
[Applause]
8th inning
starts with jonathan india against new
pitcher brad foxberger
[Applause]
the question on this one simply was
is it going to stay fair and fair it did
stay
3-3 game bottom of the ninth the stretch
by hater here it is
on the ground stabbed by urias there's
one and the turn double wow
around the horn they go
started by luisa
what a play no kidding i mean that ball
could be easy going down in the corner
maybe in the game but as it turns out
look at the wrist
able to keep it in the glove and on one
knee throws a straight to colton
and they finish off the double play what
a play defensively by the brewers maybe
a game saver
they don't just get one they get two
put amanda first maybe set up the double
play
see if he gives him something to hit
here
he does and it's a base head for reya
sanders center field and garcia scores
it's 4-3 brewers
swinging 3-0 and getting the job done
stevenson to the left yelling
makes the catch tag it there the test is
on here ends it up it's an
is he okay he flips the helmet he is not
quite walking cleanly
it is a tie game at four but staggered
strides from the reds into the dungeon
[Applause]
and he rips one fair down the right
field line to the corner
that will score a run aquino digs it out
wong is in rbi double for yelich and
it's five to four tiger bats one out
another dangerous hitter and honesty's
aquino
live caught by erase
[Music]
because the reds are out of options
they're going to have wade the blade
miley
pinch hit
with the bases loaded and two outs down
three in the 11. mustabi with a 1-1
miley a bouncer over the colton wong and
the brewers win it in 11th in 11 innings
they take down the reds 7-4